one of the things that was so satisfying
about civil war was of course the Black
Panther people came out of that movie
going I want to know more about that
character what the wow factor but it's
not just stuff blowing up it definitely
is a character piece what happens now
determines what happens to the rest of
the West San Lee and Jack Kirby created
Black Panther in the early 60s and he's
been a staple of Marvel Comics 50-plus
years he's an interesting character that
is gonna be such a different thing for
the audience when the screen I couldn't
see the Black Panther living on the side
street New York I love the idea of a
superhero who lives in Africa he has to
look out for an entire nation that's a
responsibility that the other
superheroes don't commonly have even
though he's the head of a tribe he's a
hell of a lot more than that as his
powers begin to unfold that would
but don't please never I'm super excited
about when African Kings also strong
enough fast enough smart enough to do
something things that's how he's gonna
doing it's critical there's something
very special about him
people can see a superhero in a
different light different world
you